et c'est donc l'heure dont on va plus
loin comme chaque soir à 20h40 heure de
Paris on revient ensemble sur deux
informations marquantes qui font
l'actualité de la journée en compagnie
ce soir de nos chroniqueurs Gauthier
rubinski de la rédaction de France 24
bonsoir Gauthier et de Marc Seymour
journaliste collaborateur au journal Le
Monde bonsoir Marc on va plus loin tout
d'abord ce soir sur évidemment la
victoire de Lula la présidentielle
brésilienne une victoire sur le fil
50,9% des voix pour le leader du Parti
des travailleurs contre 49,1% des
suffrages pour le président sortant
jaillir bolsonaro qui ne sait toujours
pas exprimer ce qui alimente évidemment
les craintes du éventuelle contestation
des résultats Lula lui s'est exprimé peu
après sa victoire on va l'écouter
je suis ici pour gouverner ce pays
qui traverse une situation très
difficile
mais je crois qu'avec l'aide du peuple
nous trouverons une sortie pour que ce
pays puisse reprendre sa vie
démocratique de façon harmonieuse et que
nous puissions rétablir la paix entre
des gens qui ont des opinions
divergentes afin de construire le Brésil
et le monde dont nous avons besoin
Marc on l'appelle déjà le phénix du
Brésil il y a trois ans encore il était
en prison c'est une revanche incroyable
extraordinaire résurrection politique il
a fait 580 jours de prison il était
donné pour finir bon il arrive il gagne
en plus on retrouve Lula dans ce qu'il a
de de
tribal et surtout l'homme qui est aussi
un homme de compromis c'est-à-dire
d'abord il gagne avec une coalition de 9
parties sont vice-président gérardon est
un homme de droite qui était qui avait
été même un ancien adversaire à la
présidentielle qui a été gouverneur de
200 Paolo donc il joue des rassembleurs
mais malgré ça le plus difficile
commence c'est-à-dire
rappelez-vous il y a encore de moi on
disait c'est gagner d'avance au premier
tour ça se fait jouer sur le fil d'où le
risque de contestation et surtout le
bolsonarisme gagne c'est-à-dire 14 et 27
États dont les plus importants dont
celui de son Paolo Rio tout le sud-est
et ce sont des candidats de bolsonaro
qui l'emporte à la Chambre il y a c'est
le premier groupe politique avec 99 élus
au Sénat
idem donc ça va être extrêmement
difficile et je pense qu'un des
problèmes qui explique peut-être aussi
cet assourdissant silence encore
maintenant de de gerbes c'est que d'une
certaine façon Naro
peut continuer à jouer un rôle politique
clé s'il reconnaît sa défaite parce que
au niveau de la gestion des villes des
municipalités des états etc le
bolsonarisme existe et la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de essayer de
comprendre pourquoi au-delà de ce qui a
été amplement dit les fake news
etc etc etc il y a quand même quelque
chose qui fait que quasiment à brésilien
sur deux a voté pour bolsonaro et ça ça
ne sert à rien de se cacher derrière son
petit doigt en disant ce n'était que des
manipulations donc il s'agit de
comprendre pourquoi
il y a une telle importance encore
maintenant de ces gens malgré un bilan
qui est catastrophique 700 000 morts du
covid un brésilien sur trois sous le
seuil de pauvreté etc etc pourquoi
bolsonaro
finalement
perdu seulement d'un cheveu c'est ce
qu'on verra si il s'exprime en tout cas
c'est ce qu'indique un membre de son
équipe il y a quelques instants donc il
pourrait prendre la parole évidemment on
suivra ça sur notre antenne
Gauthier bolsonaro avait multiplié
durant cette campagne on s'en rappelle
les critiques sur le système selon lui
frauduleux notamment des urnes
électroniques utilisées dans le cadre de
ce vote là il reste muré dans le silence
il y a de véritables raisons de
s'inquiéter pour les heures les jours à
venir soyez éventuel contestation des de
ces résultats officiels alors il y a
deux choses il y a une voix optimiste et
c'est un peu celle que indiqué Marc à
l'instant c'est à dire que si bolsonaro
se dit je rentre dans le jeu politique à
ce moment là effectivement Marka
parfaitement raison le bolsonarisme est
quelque chose qui survivra wolsonaro
lui-même on pourra en parler plus tard
sur cette espèce de de d'esprit de
transgression qui va au-delà d'un de
classe je m'explique les partisans de
l'oula avait dit c'est assez simple
puisqu'il y a plus de pauvres qui a 4
ans à cause de bossunao notre cause est
entendue on va voter plus pour Lula or
ça n'est pas vrai or ça n'est pas vrai
or il y a même des gens pauvres qui ont
encore plus perdu sous bossunamaro et
qui vote malgré tout pour ce dernier
parce que alors parce qu'il y a la bombe
il y a là aussi je pense quelque chose
qui est dans la transgression supposée
mais le fait qu'un type comme bosonaro
tout aussi minable soit-il au fond
adresse à ces gens-là une sorte de
nourriture symbolique des gratifications
symboliques c'est-à-dire ceux qui
consiste à être dans le vent de
l'histoire ce qui consiste à protester
de manière énergique et à être
transgressif par rapport par exemple un
certain nombre de valeurs que les
précédentes présidents de Lula avez-vous
lu instauré il y a évidemment pas que ça
il y a là il y a les évidemment
l'agrobusiness qui est à fond derrière
bossunamu mais je voulais dire que parmi
ceux qui ont le plus souffert il y en a
quand même qui vote bolsonaro et puis
pour répondre à votre question sur le
mutisme actuel il y a pour moi une autre
voie qui est moins optimiste qui
consiste à voir comment bossunaru est
conseillé en ce moment par l'armée
est-ce que l'armée lui dit il faut aller
à fond il faut continuer quitte à ce
qu'on vous aide ou bien est-ce que
l'armée qui a eu beaucoup de finalement
de faveur de la part de bossunaru se dit
aujourd'hui essayons de conserver nos
faveurs et de ne pas les mettre de ne
pas les faire dépendre de bossunaru
dernier mot là-dessus je pense que si la
roue se met dans le jeu politique Brésil
il sera aussi et c'est peut-être un
élément de sa réflexion il sera aussi
vite dépassé parce qu'au fond ce qu'il a
créé il y a aussi un opportunisme de sa
part mais il paraît assez évident que
même dans son camp il y a des gens qui
sont prêts à relever le défi à reprendre
ce drapeau y compris d'une manière on va
dire un peu plus un peu plus brillante
un peu plus chatoyante un peu plus
élaboré que bossunaro lui-même en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que la marge de
manoeuvre pour Lula da Silva pour ce
nouveau mandat qui s'ouvre sera limitée
on sait que les bolsonaristes dominent
le Congrès donc c'est de toute façon un
risque une paralysie du pouvoir qui est
annoncée
un certain nombre de poids lourds de
bolsonarisme a commencé par
la représentant de la chambre leur
représentant au Sénat le nouveau
gouverneur taricieux d'effrahitas des de
200 Paolo qui joueront le jeu
avec
il négocieront etc ensuite Lula à la
différence de Dean marousseff est un
homme qui s'étissait des compromis
séducteur
donc on peut imaginer que voilà le
système ne va pas être paralysé ensuite
oui ça marche de manœuvre sera faible et
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que aujourd'hui
certains sont de spécialistes du Brésil
le vote des lésions il est du côté de
bolsonaro c'est les gens qui ont voté
bolsonaro vote pour un peu cette vision
du monde qui un mélange de libertarisme
d'évangélisme de sécurité de libération
de de vendre des armes parce que être
capable de se protéger soi-même etc etc
etc et que le vote pour lui là était
avant tout un vote de rejet à votre de
rejet de bolsonaro donc oui ça va être
compliqué mais voilà c'est pas
impossible et on peut avoir cette vision
d'un scénario optimiste tout va être
du mais évidemment
le personnage le bolsonaro a déjà montré
plusieurs fois son disons une certaine
comment dire
oui il peut être capable de d'initiative
très irrationnelle et on peut imaginer
effectivement le pire parce que c'est un
pays extrêmement tendu des fractures
sont très fortes la situation
extrêmement tendue et il y a aussi
beaucoup d'armes en circulation et on
peut imaginer un espèce de chaos ou
l'armée à la fin interviendrait non pas
pour ou contre bolsonaro pour ou contre
Lula mais simplement pour rétablir
l'ordre et et sauver les mains alors
rapidement après l'annonce de ces
résultats est beaucoup de dirigeants
étrangers aux félicité immédiatement
Lula parmi ces dirigeants étrangers il y
a eu Vladimir Poutine Moscou qui
entretient de très bonnes relations avec
le Brésil sur la question de ces
rapports avec Moscou Gauthier il n'y a
pas de volte-face attendre avec
l'élection de Lula ou la bolsonaro c'est
un peu
ils sont sur la même ligne pour détec
étrangères pour des raisons différentes
il y a quelque chose de clair pour Lula
et on a entendu des choses qui moi
personnellement mon profondément
scandalisé sur l'Ukraine sur le soutien
Poutine sur le fait que le
responsabilité dans ce qui lui arrive
qu'on aimait bien mais qu'il fallait
qu'il rentre dans sa boîte pour pas
mettre en danger la paie mondiale donc
là est-ce qu'on peut considérer que
c'est quelque chose d'adresser à une
certaine gauche brésilienne qui part un
réflexe pavlovien penserait toujours que
c'est en Russie qu'il y a la patrie des
travailleurs et des paysans si tenter
qu'il y ait jamais existé ça c'est
quelque chose qui est éminemment
contestable et qui expliquerait cette
relation avec Poutine mais c'est une
complaisance une complaisance avec
toujours la même idée c'est que les
États-Unis étant par définissons
l'empire du mal et de l'impérialisme
précisément les restes le reste même
l'impérialisme russe passe en dessous du
tapis et c'est ça qui fait
qu'éventuellement Lula moi j'étais très
surpris la chose parce que il perd un
petit peu de son étoffe aussi qui était
quand il a été pour les premières fois
président il avait quelque chose d'un
message universel qui s'adressait
justement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
étaient opprimé il y avait vous voyez
quelque chose et elle roule aujourd'hui
il a gardé ça mais sous une forme
presque implicite c'est-à-dire qu'il est
un peu le patriarche et la manière dont
il s'est adressé justement à Zelenski où
qu'il a qui enfin caractériser ce
conflit en Ukraine avec quelque chose
d'un peu condescendant en disant moi je
connais les choses bon alors s'il vous
plaît les petits là le petit Zelensky
arrêtez de arrêter de faire le malin
il y a toujours eu deux responsabilités
dans une guerre dit-il avoir mais voyez
cet esprit un peu j'en ai vécu j'ai de
la bouteille donc s'il vous plaît ne
venez pas m'embêter avec avec des
guerres de ce type là et donc la raison
pour celle que j'ai expliqué également
voudrais qu'on soit conciliant avec
Poutine la transition est tout trouvé
avec notre deuxième thème non on va plus
loin ce soir l'Ukraine donc et la
décision pas réussi ce week-end de
suspendre l'accord sur le transport des
céréales conclut sous l'égide des
Nations Unies et de la Turquie en
juillet dernier des céréales vitales
pour l'approvisionnement alimentaire
mondial les exportations de céréales ont
repris aujourd'hui avec l'appui de l'ONU
et de la Turquie au moins 10 cargo ont
pu s'engager les cales pleines dans le
couloir maritime céréales et sans que la
Russie ne s'y oppose avec les armes
alors comment l'interpréter
ils peuvent l'interrompre quand ils
veulent et la menacer la shoygu a
rappelé encore aujourd'hui que s'il n'y
a pas les Russes dans la corde cet
accord est très dangereux voilà ce qu'on
appelle une menace plus les mots le mot
exact il avait employé mais bon la
menace est assez explicite alors ce
qu'il faut voir c'est d'abord pourquoi
les Russes ont fait ça alors le prétexte
ça a été l'attaque alors la profondément
humiliante avec des drones des drones
aériens et des drones maritimes des
Ukrainiens sur le port de Sébastopol la
plus grande base
militaire russe en Crimée bon
alors les rues disent qu'il y a eu des
dégâts mineurs apparemment il y a eu
quatre bateaux touchés dont leur nouveau
navire amiral amiral Markov qui a été
touché le précédent avait été coulé il y
a quelques mois donc c'est assez
humiliant pour les Russes exactement
comme quand il y a vu la taxe sur le
pont donc d'une certaine façon au delà
des bombardements sur les centrales
électriques et tout ce qui fait la vie
quotidienne pour espérer casser le moral
des Ukrainiens la Russie se devait de
réagir par ailleurs
cet accord arrivé à échéance le 19
novembre
alors cet accord est fondamental parce
que bon la rue l'Ukraine c'est le
cinquième exportateur mondial de
céréales ce qui n'est pas rien la Russie
je crois c'est le premier alors voilà
donc le si la mer Noire est totalement
paralysé parce que si évidemment les
rues s'empêchent les exportations
craignaient exportations russes par la
mare seront difficiles etc bon on voit
déjà le cours des céréales a commencé à
flamber et c'est
entraîné dans les effets collatéral de
cette guerre énormément de pays et
notamment les pays africains alors
l'Union européenne aide l'Ukraine il y a
déjà 60% à peu près des exportations
ukrainiennes qui ne passent plus par la
mer Noire qu'utilisent qui passe par les
trains qui vont jusqu'à la Baltique etc
mais ça reste un enjeu crucial et
symboliquement pour les Russes c'était
quand même un des terrains où le seul où
il y avait jusqu'ici malgré la guerre un
minimum de coopération qui restait et le
fait qu'on arrête ou que donc à chaque
instant les Russes peuvent couper ça
c'est extrêmement préoccupant Gauthier
cette attaque sur la flotte Russie en
Crimée c'est effectivement un faux
prétexte de la part de la Russie qui
était de toute façon insatisfaite de
l'accord qui avait été conclu en juillet
dernier oui sans enlever effectivement à
cette attaque le caractère humiliant
comme disait Marc parce qu'en plus
Sébastopol c'est quelque chose de
essentiel je me rappelais simplement
qu'il y a quelques années Vladimir
Poutine avait fait le chemin depuis
Moscou en moto avec des bikers
d'inspiration justement d'extrême droite
pour aller jusqu'à Sébastopol vous voyez
ça c'est pas n'importe quel endroit mais
le fond de l'affaire c'est que les rues
s'étaient profondément insatisfaits d'un
accord pourquoi parce que cet accord
même s'il libère les possibilités
d'exportation des céréales russes et
bien ensuite elle se retrouve coincée
par les sanctions ces exportations et
que une façon de dire c'est ce que avait
dit la porte-parole du mythe du
ministère des Affaires étrangères
magasin avait dit mais au fond cet
accord ne résout en rien l'exportation
de nos biens puisqu'ils sont coincés
après autrement dit si vous voulez que
nous appliquions notre partie de
l'accord sur ce corridor justement vers
vers la mer Noire et bien alléger les
sanctions et à ce moment-là il y aura
pas de problème donc d'une part c'est ça
et puis d'autre part par rapport à
l'Afrique c'est aussi la tactique
actuelle des Russes de renverser la
charge de la culpabilité c'est à dire
que les Russes vont dire vous voyez bien
si nous ne pouvons pas vous
approvisionner c'est parce que
l'Occident nous empêche d'exporter et
donc pour des raisons totalement
égotistes on va dire la Russie à sa
stratégie mais elle va faire croire aux
Africains qui dépendent de ces céréales
russes que si au fond une maison pas
aussi les ont à un prix pour éviter
c'est parce que justement
sur
l'approvisionnement alimentaire mondial
par rapport à cette suspension actuelle
donc comme on est déjà dans une
situation mondiale où les facteurs
d'inflation ne manquent pas
l'envol du prix des céréales aura des
peu avoir des effets dévastateurs alors
peut-être un d'animaux sur le rôle assez
ambigueux joué par la Turquie dans cette
histoire la Turquie qui se pose en
médiateur je citeper douanes pour le
bien de l'humanité dans cette histoire
des céréales mais ne condamne pas pour
autant la décision russe de ce week-end
la Turquie joue sur tous les tableaux il
est dans son jeu d'équilibre habituel
la Turquie fait partie de l'OTAN la
Turquie a voté tous les textes toutes
les résolutions à l'ONU condamnant ce
qui s'est passé en Ukraine et en même
temps la Russie n'applique pas les
sanctions
voilà donc c'est un jeu la Turquie a
joué regga perdan a joué dans l'espace
que lui a laissé Poutine mais dont cette
espèce telle a bien joué ses cartes et
aujourd'hui effectivement ça reste quand
même le seul qui a réalisé ce dont
révèle président français dire être
capable de parler au dos oui en deux
mots il y a deux choses qui avantagent
les Turcs c'est que les Russes pour
essayer de contourner les sanctions crée
des sociétés exportatrices en Turquie et
que en plus de ça si vous voulez vu les
difficultés de l'économie turque en
crise bien ça fait un ballon d'air pur
simplement le problème c'est qu'un jour
ça peut se retourner contre la Turquie
si par exemple les sanctions devaient
être resserrées à ce moment-là on visera
un petit peu cette cette espèce de
laxisme ou de permissivité turque merci
beaucoup Gauthier merci Marc pour vos
éclairages ce soir c'est la fin déjà on
va plus loin retrouver aussi sur notre
site et nos réseaux sociaux l'actualité
continue surprendre 24 restez avec
[Musique]